- I feel like we're similar,
when we toured together,
I feel like you don't really
get embarrassed much, right?
You're just kind of full on like, well.
- I honestly think I learned that from you
because normally I, I do
get easily embarrassed,
but uh, it was my- it was my
beginning of quarantine spiral.
I think I was just kinda
like, I need to laugh,
I need other people to laugh,
so I'm just gonna- I'm just
gonna do a couple chip dips.
- I loved it, um, but there
was- there was a moment
that you were embarrassed recently, right?
- I, yeah, I'm, I embarrass myself a lot,
but I um, I went to the
CMAs, they had them in person
and were able to really do it safely
and get everyone tested and
be in the same room together
and afterwards, I- I don't
know Miranda Lambert very well,
she's like someone that I
randomly had not crossed paths
with, paths with my country community yet,
and so I still get
really nervous around her
cause I'm like, I just
want to be your friend.
And I was talking to her manager
and I was, uh- her manager had those,
you know those really
expensive wine glasses
that are like paper thin, like
you're scared to hold them
because you think they're
gonna shatter in your hands.
- Yes and I have actually
- You know?
- shattered a couple, but yes.
(audience laughs)
- Mm hmm. Oh.
- Well yep, so I did that too.
I was- I was talking to her
manager and Miranda's here,
her manager's here, I'm here, me.
And I'm drinking it and it shatters,
it hit my tooth and it
shattered in my mouth,
- In your- Oh my gosh!
- In my mouth, cut my lip,
and I had to like spit out bloody glass
and like run to the
bathroom in front of her
and I think everyone was
like, did she just eat glass?
Like, is that a thing that she does?
Because I don't really
know anyone in the room
and so then I had to go to the bathroom
make my lip stop bleeding
and then I was like,
well, I can't leave now
because I need people to
not think that I'm weird
cause I care way too much
about what people think of me.
And so then I had to
go back into the party
hold my lip so it stops bleeding
I'm like trying to act casual
around Miranda Lambert.
Anyway, anyways.
- She, she said, I love it.
She said, you know, we
still don't know each other.
Oh, she knows you, you just
I was the girl that ate
glass in front of you.
Oh!
yes of course!
(audience laughs)
- How do you come back from that?
You just don't.
- [Kelly] You left a Mark.
And I like it.
It was memorable.